drakenbezos on instagram no no no don't
do this what
is it
i can't i can't i can't
jeff says started from the bottom now
we're here
champagne poppy
holy jeff knows about that's not true
that's not [ __ ] real that's real
that's me today yeah that's real i took
a screenshot from his what big bezos in
the comments
the best part is like jeff bezos is like
buried in the comments you gotta like
scroll for it
it's [ __ ] crazy that drake is
fangirling
i mean that's what happened sorry no
he's just trying to make his way into
the billionaire world that's all
yeah but i mean isn't it funny that that
the way he says that is just like every
fan ever that's true
holy [ __ ] dude i can't believe jeff
knows who i am dude
he's kind of oh he's big he's definitely
big now yeah bezos is on that gear he's
big
yo
what were we talking about this no okay
so bezos is
bezos's bezos's
big bezos
white or his girlfriend now that like
reporter girl yeah yeah yeah so she was
dating
go look at her like dating history she
cheated on her husband
who was a huge agent
like a hollywood agent she was married
to him and then before that she was
married to like a super successful
football player so
she knows these guys yeah she knows what
they like yeah
she's a man eater yep that's what you're
saying as i mean yeah she's a
billionaire man eater yeah
hope she breaks jeff's heart
i hope she just sends him on a [ __ ]
spiral that he starts like a fitness
account yeah so it's getting huge
starts doing weird trends yeah
think about the one that left
bro if they started a couple's tick tock
account that'd be so funny
well oh well no it's only a matter of
time should i chew him up spit him out
yeah so you better enjoy it while he has
it
oh wouldn't that be great if there's a
leak of bezos being the please bro why
are you doing that yeah yeah
damn
holy yeah so she had kids with her
second husband and then cheated on him
with jeff and then left them lord yeah
for jeffy
and this guy was oh by the way this guy
is also a billionaire
just not quite
the billionaire that jeff is what i'm
saying she she understands these types
of men
is that him
what
what's his name
patrick whitesell look up his net worth
co-ceo of wme
sick
or he's he's worth like 400 million or
something
450 million
that's cool
like imagine being worth
being that successful worth half a
billion dollars guys with a beautiful
family yeah and then you get cocked by
the the the the guy who owns the website
that you get your [ __ ] diapers and
baby forms the richest man in the world
yeah
yeah
guys if you don't really understand this
segment uh let me explain okay imagine
like a dollar
now imagine 450 million of them
that's about where this guy
stood in society
and uh yeah it's good to put things in
perspective yeah and then so if you
could imagine that same dollar and jeff
and not picture jeff and that same
dollar
now multiply it by 7 billion or
something
and then add another 30 billion on top
of that that's like about where he's at
so
oh and then add another 100 on top
100 billion sorry add another 100
billion on top
so it's about
thirty nine billion of those one dollars
yeah it sounds a bit yeah
money is [ __ ] up
yeah
yeah dude it is a little shroom epiphany
that's my deep ass tape he's [ __ ] up
that was a yeah actually for goofy
shroom epiphanies
you know my whole life i always wanted
to try like a psychedelic but i always
thought you know
i was like scared of them
i always thought it was like super cool
to do a psychedelic
and then
i'm just like
on the shrooms and i all i could think
was
okay
like what okay
all right guys
that's cool waited a while to do this
[Laughter]
it's not that bad that's why you should
do more no dude you need to do more so
you can see the eyes in your sandwich
you don't really know life until your
food is breathing
i think a lot of our food used to
breathe don't you worry
you